Chris Hutchins: Founder and CEO of Simple AI Solutions, where he builds AI driven sales.
Chris Hutchins: And marketing systems for owners and consultants. Automating the routine parts of running a business. But here's the tension. I want to get into this one. The more he automates, the more his real thesis is about responsibility and the human skills.
Chris Hutchins: More his real thesis is about responsibility and the human skills that matter more, not less. Chris, welcome to the Signal Room.
Chris Bruner: Thank you for having me. It is a honor to be here, Chris. I I appreciate it.
Chris Hutchins: Well first and foremost I just wanna say congratulations. I understand you had your fourth child, so congrats to you and your wife.
Chris Bruner: Yeah. Yes, thank you. It is definitely sleepless nights, but it's it is amazing. children are just amazing and yes, number four, so it's been it's been a journey.
Chris Hutchins: I I I think once you hit number four you you you've you've achieved a a whole nother level. 'cause for me, having two, I loved them dearly. They're both in their thirties now. but you know, the those those early years, man, when you're the the whole sleep thing, that that was legit. You get adjusted to one and then you find out you need a different manual because no two of them are alike, right?
Chris Bruner: Yeah.
Chris Bruner: That's right. I know. I know. It is. It is definitely it's definitely been a whirlwind. I I was going into going into this one and thought for sure I was like, okay, it will be good. Give me a week or two. I'll be like back at it. And yeah, almost three, four weeks in and I'm still still playing some catch up and but it's good. It's good.
Chris Hutchins: Yeah.
Chris Hutchins: Yeah. Well I mean obviously we know that you're father, but I'd love to hear a little bit more about who you are and what you build at Simple AI solutions.
Chris Bruner: Yeah, of course. So yeah, Simple AI Solutions. It's an AI agency. We help businesses with lead generation, automations, as you know, not just taking the AI tools, but leveraging it with the right type of strategy. you know, as as anyone who's dabbled with AI, with with
Chris Hutchins: Yeah.
Chris Bruner: Which most people have nowadays, leveraging AI in the correct way is huge because you can waste time, you can waste money, you can do things that make your business or make it sound or look like AI, but leveraging AI in the right way with the redundant tasks is typically what we focus on. and so yeah, it's it's coming in as a growth partner for.
Chris Bruner: businesses, small to mid sized businesses and helping them leverage AI in the ways that actually, you know, move the needle and help them in either save time with automations, save money with automations, or you know, try to gain more leads and more opportunity through different strategies with AI. And so
Chris Hutchins: I well like like most things that that I've come across when I talk to people about AI, there's there's a backstory and I I'd love to hear a little bit about yours and how did you get here and what what was it actually that inspired you to to start doing this kind of work and and to s to support all kinds of different businesses, owners, consultancies for various verticals.
Chris Bruner: Yeah, yeah, yeah. Of course. So yeah. So I have been doing this for around nine ish months now. So it's fairly newer journey for me. and before this, and and you know, I actually worked in healthcare for most of my career. I most of my career actually was like healthcare. and then also I worked in at like my my church actually, which is a big mega church, you know, leading
Chris Hutchins: Right.
Chris Bruner: these big events and projects for the church. And and you know, I kind of had both of these career paths going where both of them within the hospital and within the church, I was leading events and leading projects and it really kind of sparked my interest in project management. and so I actually went back to school. Luckily, luckily at the hospital they offered free schooling.
Chris Bruner: And I took as much advantage of that as I could. I I got a bachelor's degree, I got two master's degrees, all all paid for just through the the the hospital, which is amazing. such like a game changer. And and a lot of that focus was on business and on project management. and so I I after I finished my schooling, you know, I I started looking into other opportunities and really kind of was
Chris Hutchins: Right.
Chris Bruner: It was kind of, you know, a few years ago when AI, you know, Chat GBT was coming out and is being used a lot more. And I was thinking like, what really is gonna be like what really is gonna be like really relevant, you know, years down the line, years down the road from now, you know, and and I I had seen this like business model of running an AI agency where you're helping businesses, you know, leverage AI, right? Because AI is
Chris Bruner: being leveraged in all sorts of different ways now. But you know, especially when it first started coming out and first started being used, it was the big major companies that were, you know, that can invest millions and millions of dollars into AI to create these efficiencies. And and you know, my business model is not necessarily to help them, right? It's to help the small to mid-size businesses because the small to mid-size businesses are are typically
Chris Bruner: They understand that AI is a game changer, but they just don't understand exactly how best can I leverage it, how best can I use that? And so I kind of come in as a growth partner and help them achieve those goals as within their business, leveraging AI, you know, and obviously AI can't solve everything, right? But it's doing a deep analysis and trying to figure out where the bottlenecks are and seeing if there is.
Chris Hutchins: Right.
Chris Bruner: a efficient way to leverage AI in that. And so that's you know, initially that's kind of how it came to be, just kind of discovering different business models. And you know, I've always always kind of had that entrepreneur itch. this is the first time I've I've really kind of gone out and and pursued it. And it has been a journey. I have so much more respect over anyone who's gone out and started a business because
Chris Bruner: It is it is difficult. It is challenging. you know, it is definitely a huge blessing. It comes with so many great benefits of like being able to work remote and be flexible with my schedule and be there for you know, my family and my kids games and you know, this and that. And and you know, and but it it is definitely challenging, right? You have to work, you have to work to get money on the table and
Chris Hutchins: Yeah.
Chris Hutchins: For sure.
Chris Bruner: It's not you know, those those you don't just get a clock in and clock out, right? It's we you're running this thing. And so yeah, it's it's definitely been definitely been very interesting.
Chris Hutchins: Yeah. That's right. Yeah. Well, I yet I I think f I I may have s shared this with you before, but you already know it anyway. I thought a CEO well, I thought I knew what a CEO really was, what I've discovered, at least early on, it says you're chief everything officer. It's just that's how it is. so if you could kind of talk a little bit about really I think
Chris Bruner: Yeah. Yeah.
Chris Hutchins: There's two two different things that that come to mind. So helping them with AI do thing to do certain things to make things more efficient is that's a pretty common thing. But you said something previously when we've spoken that I I think is interesting. So when you're talking about a done for you AI system, what does that look like? I think that's important for people to understand because it's like it's not a magic bullet.
Chris Bruner: Yeah.
Chris Hutchins: But w what exactly is that from your perspective and how d how should they think about that?
Chris Bruner: Yeah, totally. So a done for you AI service, depending obviously it depends on exactly what the service is. And and for me, like I create a customized plan for each each client of mine. And and and so what I will do, typically what it looks like if it if we're focusing on lead generation, you know, I might a done for you service is you don't have to do
Chris Bruner: anything to get those leads right because I'm I'm gonna be pers I'm gonna be leveraging AI in the strategy to create those leads for you and your business and and so typically what that looks like is matching it up with the correct strategy which there's a couple different angles I I typically will take clients depending on
Chris Bruner: You know, exactly what they want to pursue and exactly kind of what their goals are. but starting conversations, right? And and leveraging AI with the redundant tasks, right? When you one one avenue is cold email outreach, right? Which you and me and everyone who is has any type of business email probably gets a million emails and it is
Chris Bruner: Tedious, right? Most of the time we don't even open them because it's so much, right? And and you know, and and so in 99% of all that is leveraging AI with cold email, but doing it the way it's been done for the last 15 years, right? Doing a very direct method where it's like, you know, this is my service, this is how it can help, right? And if you don't have any relationship, if you're read if you're doing that to cold.
Chris Hutchins: Right.
Chris Bruner: Cold prospects, right? You're not there, it's not gonna go anywhere, right? Because people, it's just so overused nowadays. And so leveraging cold email outreach, right, in a scalable way, right, which is where the AI tools come into play, but also making it personal and also making it making it a value added first, which which is huge. you know, and
Chris Bruner: And what that does mean is that does maybe mean like an extra meeting with the prospect or an extra, you know, like you're kind of giving value to them first, but it creates the opportunity to build trust, right? Especially nowadays where you never know. I'm I'm it's amazing. It's kind of scary. some of the things AI can do where it can take this video recording and make me into a cartoon or make me into
Chris Bruner: A completely different person with a completely different voice, but doing exactly everything I'm doing and saying, which you it's it's kind of scary. You don't exactly know, right? And so building trust today with cold prospects is a must have. It it it you gotta have it, right? Because it's it's it's huge. You have to you have to build trust. And so this is kind of how I structure the outreach and doing it in a scalable way. And so some of the
Chris Bruner: Some of the AI tools that come into play is being able to leverage creating a cold. There's a handful of steps for anyone who's done cold email. I'm sure you know, right? But there's a handful of steps of creating you know, the the domains, the email inboxes, the type of messaging you're gonna send out, which is huge. making sure those emails and domains are are warmed up and the emails are done correctly and and sending out, you know, a
Chris Bruner: a right type of sequence that you know it makes it seem personable, right? And then leveraging AI and the messaging with the AI tools nowadays, you can you can very much mess you can very much like have mentioned their name and their business and something personable about them and their business that you can send to each and every person. And you know when you're emailing a couple
Chris Bruner: you know, a hundred and two hundred people, you you could do that manually. It would take it would take, you know, some time, right? But but email nowadays, like you can easily leverage these AI tools and and do, you know, ten thousand contacts, which is typically what I I do within my clients. And and it's it's very interesting. You know, another way that we leverage AI tools for as like a done free service, right? As you are
Chris Bruner: outreaching to so many different prospects, you start to get a lot of like responses. And if anyone has any experience in this game, they know like speed to lead is huge, right? Being able to respond to a lead is is huge. It's so, so important to respond quickly and efficiently. You know, and and being able to leverage and often half the time those responses are redundant responses. It's the same type of questions
Chris Bruner: That you can train an AI agent to respond immediately and and to respond to prompt certain questions to almost pre qualify prospects even more and to even schedule a meeting with you. And so that's that's typically how we leverage AI agents within cold outreach, as like a done for you service. and so yeah.
Chris Hutchins: Right.
Chris Hutchins: You you you you talked you touched on something that I think is important and I that from my perspective I think it's a differentiator. you know trust is not not something to take lightly and I know that you don't. it's a cons it's been a concern to me 'cause I've been on the on one side of the fence for such a long time. like 'cause I've been working in the provider sector in healthcare. And it it's I'm very s very, very sensitive to
Chris Hutchins: the way that I communicate with potential clients for the reasons that you you mentioned. I mean trust is something that you it it it's very important. you've used the term entrepreneurial responsibility. And I just want to have you talk about that a a little bit more specifically. One of the things that is always a concern when somebody's considering doing this kind of outreach campaign is I've got a reputation and I've got credibility.
Chris Hutchins: How are you going to make sure that y you're bringing the right kind of message and you're representing me and my brand in a way that I can be confident that your your AI is not gonna run amok and and do damage?
Chris Bruner: Yeah, totally, totally. Which is is totally like probably the boils down to like the biggest fear with anyone using AI for any type of response because you don't want it saying something that doesn't represent you and your business and saying something that is wrong and making it, you know, making it and then that boils down to how you one, how you train the AI, to really understanding from like, you know.
Chris Hutchins: Yeah.
Chris Bruner: me as the provider of this service to understanding how my clients really want to communicate, how they communicate, and really understanding like who who like they are communicating to, right? With most people, it's a specific type of, you know, ideal client that, you know, typically, you know, you want to with any type of outreach, you do want to try to like
Chris Bruner: rub a little bit of like a a interest point if that's a a pain point for them or if that's something they're interested in in something that will kind of hook them in, right? But you you have to you have to still be you know cautious with that right because you don't want to come off too harsh you don't want to come off you know too nonchalant you want to be professional right and and it all boils down to really how you train the AI right and obviously like
Chris Bruner: Like any of us has any trained any type of AI, even a chat bot that we've we've gone back and forth with, right? The more information you can give it, the better. Right. And the nice part is is that AI does learn. And so is it perfect 100% of the time? No, right? I'm not gonna sit here and say like everything's absolutely perfect and rainbow and butterflies, and but what what I will say is that it it learns and we try.
Chris Bruner: train it to as you know if there is a mistake, immediately train it so that mistake doesn't happen again. you know, and and in, you know, obviously it I think it really boils down to, yeah, those two things. One, really making sure from the get-go you understand how the communication is going from, you know, from to the prospects and then also how the training it as you go along.
Chris Hutchins: Mm-hmm.
Chris Bruner: And so that's that's really what comes to mind. and so yeah.
Chris Hutchins: Yeah. Let's see you're you're talking about the training aspect of it. I think that it's a it's an interesting thing. And I think it leads to another area that I I'd love to hear you talk about. Because when you're doing these things, one of the things that people can are always concerned about is it's gonna d displace me, do I lose my job? T talk about the human skills that you see becoming more valuable in your experience as you're helping clients to to roll these things out.
Chris Bruner: Yeah.
Chris Bruner: Yeah, honestly, in any it's so funny, in a world of like virtual meetings are bigger than ever, right? H being able to have like a face-to-face conversation, even if it's over Zoom, but like being able to talk to people and connect with people. And honestly, like I think there's a a something valuable in just being real. Like, I don't know. I'm I'm I'm sure I've shared this with you before, but like as a business owner.
Chris Hutchins: Yeah.
Chris Hutchins: Right.
Chris Bruner: I'm not like a super like salesperson. Like I'm I'm not like I'm not like super technical with or super like great at sales, but what I do is I just try to connect with my client, my my prospects. As I'm talking with them, I be real. I'm like, hey, like I'm I really want to add value. And I think being able to come to someone and be real and not like have like a perfectly polished out, like
Chris Bruner: presence or live or whatever, like it like like having that sense of realness is huge because it shows like the human side of us, right? Which I think is is is more and more valuable in where every single conversation, every single email getting sent out is getting, you know, analyzed through AI and and filtered through AI. And it's like polished perfectly, right? But being able to like come to someone face to face, even over a virtual meeting and just be real.
Chris Bruner: Is is huge. It builds that connection. We're in a world where we're so like spread apart and you know in different places where connection is like key. And that's honestly, it's never going away because people the ultimately people want to connect with people. People don't want to connect with AI. People want to connect with people. And so I think that's that's that's one thing that comes to mind.
Chris Hutchins: Yeah, and that that's one of the things that stuck out to me the first couple of conversations you and I had. This is something that you feel deeply about and it's per it's personal for you. would you I think that makes all the difference in the world because the the situations that we're seeing where the technologies are advancing so quickly, the differentiators are gonna be do you have a business partner that you trust who can learn with you? because when these shifts happen.
Chris Hutchins: You you don't want somebody who's short-sighted, well, we designed it to do this and that's the part we're gonna do. but it's more of a hey, listen, this is your business and it means a lot to me that you're trusting me to help you with it. And I think that's a that's always that's a huge credit to you, Chris, in the way that you operate. And I really respe respect that. we talk about the idea of having hands-on versus hands-on the wheel with this kind of automation. Done for you automation is really, really powerful for sure. Where should an owner keep their hands on the wheel?
Chris Bruner: Yeah.
Chris Bruner: owners should definitely keep the hands on the wheel when when it comes to like thinking about a process, right? AI is great to come up with ideas. It's great to do, like it's perfect to do for redundant tasks, things that are just like time eaters. But when it comes to like creating something or when it comes to like like the like the you know, the thought behind like your business and your your clients.
Chris Bruner: Like you gotta make sure like you're not letting AI become your brain, right? Because you gotta have like self-thought. You gotta be able to think about these things through yourself. Because AI, even though it is great, it does mess up at times, right? And you'll you'll find yourself if you're letting AI create your entire project plan and create everything you do, you'll you'll find yourself like running into some embarrassing moments because there's gonna be
Chris Bruner: a little mix-ups or there's gonna be things where you're like, actually that's not what I wanted. Right. But leverage it, still use it, but keep that like filter through yourself, right? And and so leveraging it in the process is great, but definitely make sure it doesn't don't let AI take over your your brains. And so
Chris Hutchins: Right. I th that's the most simple and clear message I've heard in a while and and I like that. we you know we we we definitely have to think about it differently that it's not gonna take your job. What makes it valuable is you and how you operate it and how you decide and have good judgment in terms of what you should and shouldn't do. And the answer is different in it in many, many cases.
Chris Bruner: It it's tempting though.
Chris Bruner: Yeah.
Chris Hutchins: one of the things that is common though across the, and I know you saw you told me this before, and it and it's certainly been my experience, poor data and technical debt not only are problematic, because there's a lot of that out there, but these are the very things that can quietly sink AI projects. What has to be true in order to really prevent that? And and w how do we need how do we think about that? Well, because the automation can't pay off if we don't address certain things ahead time.
Chris Bruner: Yeah, with you're talking about with like analyzing data within a business. Yeah, you know.
Chris Hutchins: Yeah, and what what you can safely build on it really matters in terms of how qual how much quality is there? Is it consistent? Do you have silos that aren't even integrated? You pick the wrong use case 'cause the data's not ready. I mean, there's a lot of ways it can go sideways.
Chris Bruner: Yeah, no, it it is very interesting. I feel like definitely with any type of like data, right? Any sensitive data, just steer clear. Yeah, right. You don't once it's once it's into, you know, into cloud, into chat GPT, you know, you don't want to put sensitive data into into these these systems, especially if they're not like a closed network system. I know certain certain certain
Chris Hutchins: Right.
Chris Bruner: platforms, you know, can be within closed network and, you know, can be more safer than others. but still understanding like, you know, I feel like when you get into, you know, the bigger corporations where where, you know, they're leveraging data in different ways, but like that's definitely a huge, huge thing that bigger corporations focus on because it there's so much data and so much information
Chris Bruner: that they're trying to filter through and create efficiencies for, which is good, but just understanding like like what you can and can't put in there, I think is is definitely definitely important. and so yeah, it's it's definitely very, very interesting.
Chris Hutchins: No, you you've you've s mu I I think I got this right baby but you spent time in higher stakes s settings and you know, for for certain if I have it right, you've done some in healthcare as well, right?
Chris Bruner: I I've done I've led done some like project management within healthcare. and so I've I've done some clinical work within healthcare and I've also l have led like process improvement projects within healthcare and so
Chris Hutchins: It it it is an interesting thing. And it it's so it is so different from from a r almost any other industry for a variety of reasons. But I think the piece that you know comes through for me what you're talking about is just the the the way that you're treating it. For no doesn't really matter what the industry is, but there's there's a responsibility lens that that you you apply to it. talk about that w what what the lens change actually looks like.
Chris Hutchins: When a bad output isn't doesn't necessarily mean it's a lost sale, but it's a patient.
Chris Bruner: Yeah, yeah, with a you know, especially especially in healthcare, which I it's interesting because I actually within my AI agency, I actually haven't done too many healthcare. I've I've done some process improvement projects within healthcare and have leveraged, you know, AI a little bit in the process there, but I haven't I haven't not necessarily with my
Chris Bruner: Business. That was kind of before. And and you know, healthcare is very interesting. It is not like any other industry because, you know, ultimately it boils down to the type of care that you're giving to these patients, which, you know, like any anyone who's worked in healthcare, right? You imagine that patient as like your grandma, right? Or your mom, right? Or someone who who is near and dear to you because
Chris Bruner: It puts you in a place where you're like, okay, I'm gonna do this for the right reasons, right? And and and you know, when it comes to, you know, leveraging AI within certain processes in healthcare, yeah, it can definitely be, it can definitely add certain efficiencies, it can definitely help in certain areas. but it's definitely one of those areas that you do, you do gotta be careful, right? There's a bunch of laws. There's the HIPAA laws, there's there's a bunch of laws you gotta be really careful with.
Chris Bruner: You can't just put out information into into the internet about patients, about processes, right? And it's it's interesting. And so it's it's definitely healthcare is one of those industries that lean a lot more on like we're going to even if we're gonna fall a lot more on the safer side of using like even if that means like not taking advantage of
Chris Bruner: everything AI can do, but like let's be more safe with like and leverage it a little bit. Like I feel like that's where I typically see healthcare leveraging AI in the more simpler ways, but but in a definitely safer way. just because there's there's a lot a lot of laws behind it.
Chris Hutchins: w is as we're kind of getting close to wrapping here, something that y you mentioned to me last time just it's kinda made me smile if I think about it. and it's legacy. And what you mentioned to me is the fact that you're you're starting to teach your son a little about about AI and you know w what the entrepreneurial responsibility is. I think that's phenomenal. Talk a little bit about that and in
Chris Hutchins: Wha wha what kind of inspired you to to tackle that? 'Cause I think people need to need to be thinking about this and I and I love that you're you're already engaging to do that in your own family.
Chris Bruner: Yeah. Totally. Yeah. Right. One, it boils down to to like like even just I feel like for us, we think about like what does the next like five years hold, ten years hold like like with like the amount of tools and what AI can do, like I'm like thinking like ten years down the road, it's gonna look completely different, right? Or or or at least it could, right? And in there is that like, you know
Chris Hutchins: Right.
Chris Hutchins: Yeah.
Chris Bruner: Part of it, that like understanding of like just being in the field of AI is like like it is affecting every single industry in one way or another, for the most part. right. And and to sometimes it's just simple behind the scenes automations or little, you know, admin work or different things in one way or another. And so I think one, like understanding how to leverage it in the correct way.
Chris Hutchins: Right.
Chris Bruner: Is huge because there's good habits you can build with how to use AI, and there's bad habits you can build with how to use AI. And and you know, part of me I'm I'm thinking like my son, he's 10, right? And and he is growing, like I kind of shared, like into this like preteen stage where where he's like likes responsibility and he's like, you know, a lot more caring a lot more about certain things. And it's very interesting. And as I like think like this is
Chris Hutchins: Yeah.
Chris Bruner: Like especially adolescence is such a a moldable part of a a child's life. Like it is the time where like I want to invest and not just show them like like hey, like this is something that would be beneficial for you no matter what you do in the future. Like it's gonna be beneficial for you to learn and understand. But then also like, hey, like what what could you do now to build that like responsibility, to build something and
Chris Bruner: And what we've been working on is is something simple and something easy. Like we we've been working on a a little business for him called Nixon's Curbside Service, which is just a a him going out to the neighbors on our street and you know, him every week taking out their trash cans to the curb and then the next day bringing them back in, right? And making like, you know.
Chris Bruner: 10 bucks a month or something simple like that. And and it it it's very little, right? It's a for for a kid, even if he gets 10 houses, you know, that's that's still like huge, a hundred bucks a month. But but for for him, it teaches responsibility. It teaches him, him like, hey, like people are counting on you to do this, right? And and it's something that he has desire to do. We're still in the works of it. you know, having having a
Chris Bruner: You know, his little baby sister come over the last few weeks has definitely we we were like summertime is perfect and you know we're already a couple weeks into summer and it's hasn't launched yet. But it's something that we've we've you know it it excited about. He's really excited about and it's gonna teach him responsibility, it's gonna teach him a good work ethic, it's gonna teach him consistency because that's what he's gotta do. He's gotta be there every week. And and so yeah, it's
Chris Hutchins: Yeah.
Chris Bruner: It's you know, and and even though it doesn't have much to do with AI, it's still being able to teach him a little bit of the ways that, hey, you can leverage, like I even as we were like creating, you know, the logo and creating, you know, the the process and thinking through parts of it, right, getting ideas for it, I was like, hey, this is kind of like a great way to kind of you know brainstorm some ideas like.
Chris Bruner: leverage leverage AI in in just like thinking about it. Obviously make sure it's it's really doable on on our end and like real you know, 'cause it it comes up with some wild ideas sometimes, but it's it's definitely been interesting and it's been it's been a a fruitful journey. I'm we're we're both excited to to get that up and going for him. So
Chris Hutchins: Yeah.
Chris Hutchins: and I I I love that, man. Hat hat's off to you. I mean that it's it's pretty, really cool to see how you've taken this learning and the things that you're applying to your business and you're finding the ways to expose and in what you're learning and share it with with with your family like that. I think there's just a lot to be said for it. 'Cause I think the r the the harder part of the transformation we're going through is people oftentimes
Chris Hutchins: aren't hearing and they're not learning about the ways you can use it. There's plenty of people talking about the things you should be frightened about. But again, just love that you're you're doing that and man, I'd love to have you back to hear some some updates on that 'cause I I think I'm excited to to see that you're I I know you guys are gonna have some fun, but you're gonna you're gonna have some success too. And but not nothing like seeing a smile on your child's face because they just achieved something that they never knew that they could. So
Chris Bruner: Yeah.
Chris Bruner: Yeah, yeah. No it yeah.
Chris Hutchins: You know, I I can't wait to hear updates on that one. t talk to me a little bit about what what you see coming. What what's next for you and your your business and you are there things that you're you're kind of mulling over or working on now that are are yet you know, dead ahead? Or you know, what do you see coming from?
Chris Bruner: Yeah, it's it's very interesting. You know, leveraging it, you know, trying to stay having an AI agency where you are creating automations, where you are helping with lead generation in the strategy behind it. there's it feels like every single month there's always something new. There's always, you know, a new tool or a new this or a new that. And it's it's very interesting. You know, I've
Chris Bruner: I'd love to say like staying on top of it or like, you know, staying like hitting like a a you know, a certain amount of clients I want to hit this month, you know, or this this year, or whatever, whatever it might look like, right? Like I feel like that's like obviously those things are the things I I pursue, obviously, within a business. But like what's more important for me is is really just the the impact, right? Being able to
Chris Bruner: come in and help solve specific a specific issue within a business and help a business owner get through that and grow. is in the impact that it makes on them, right? I feel like it it it it makes like a very similar impact on me because it's like it's beyond just a a paycheck. It's really it's helping someone solve a problem in a
Chris Bruner: in something that is like one of the most important things to them, their business, right? And and that's why it's is so much more fruitful, I feel like, and so much more meaningful to help these, you know, smaller to midsized businesses, right? Because you can you it it makes such an impact for them and what they're doing, which is ultimately it's it's huge, right? To be able to have have that impact. And it's a you know, honestly and and
Chris Bruner: mentioning legacy, I feel like I feel like I I've gotta say it because it's it's something that is truly probably the most important thing to me is obviously my family, but then also like my my like just being a good steward of what I have and and being honoring to the Lord. being being a Christian is a huge part of my life. And I I feel like I I try to bring him into, you know, most most conversations and
Chris Hutchins: Mm-hmm.
Chris Bruner: And just being a good steward of like what the Lord has given me and and within this business and ultimately, you know, all the glory goes to him and and so that's that is you know, when I think about my legacy and impact and what the future holds, that's that's really what it is. And so yeah.
Chris Hutchins: th I I I love that and I I totally respect that because there's there's just there's a no unfortunately there's just a lot of people out there right now they're they're look they're more fearful and apprehensive than they need to be. but the the things that are gonna make a difference are the things that you're talking about. You know, having having the a core value system that actually comes from you know y your your belief system I think that's it's just too
Chris Hutchins: It's too important for people to to not hear that. And I and I I I hope people are hearing it loud and clear 'cause th you wanna work with people who have integrity and who actually care about getting things right. not just getting re good result, but getting things right. those things typically are not opposed to each other. And I I just love that about how you're how you're leading your family, how you're leading your your business and the impact you're having on your church and your community.
Chris Hutchins: Keep up the good work, Chris. I I g I gotta say thank you so much for for coming on the show. it it's been a blast. every time we get to talk, I I obviously learning some things from you and I really appreciate and respect what you're doing. can't wait to hear updates. I know there's gonna be a lot of great things for you to come. again, congrats on your podcast. I I'm super excited to to see what you do there as well. but again, thank you so much for being on the show.
Chris Bruner: Yeah.
Chris Bruner: Thank you. Yeah, thank you so much. It was an honor. It was a great conversation. yeah, I really appreciate it. Thank you, Chris.
Chris Hutchins: Congrats again on to you and your your lovely wife and your family. amazing. I I'm I'm very excited for you. for for my listeners, you're I'm gonna make sure you have all that you need to know to be able to reach out to Chris and learn about his business and under learn about his podcast. We'll put the links all out there for you so you so you can follow up with him. I'm sure you've heard some things today that make you realize, huh.
Chris Hutchins: I could probably use some help here. please don't hesitate to reach out to Chris. I don't think you'll regret that decision for a second. So from the Signal Room, that's all we have for today, and we'll see you next time.